مرحبا نبدا كواليس هذا الاسبوع مع العوده
الفنيه اللي سجلتها الفنانه ميس حمدان
باغنيه هذه المره بعنوان شيك ومهندم واللي
تعاونت فيها مع المؤلف والملحن عزيز
الشافعي والموزع هاني يعقوب ميس صورت
الاغنيه بطريقه الفيديو كليب وطرحتها على
مواقع التواصل وكمان المنصات الالكترونيه
وقدمت خلالها نفسها مو بس كمغنيه لكن
كفنانه استعراضيه وقالت انه عندها كثير
مفاجات خلال الفتره القادمه الاغنيه دي
انا بحبها قوي وعزيزه على قلبي جدا وزي ما
بيقولوا كده بتاعي بعد فتره طويله جدا كان
دايما ببقى عايزه اغني يمكن بس ما كانش
بيبقى في توفيق في حته الغناء والناس كلها
دائما تقول لي ميس نفسنا نشوفك في
الاستعراضي في راس عشان دايما مرات على
الانستجرام وعلى التيك توك مرات يعني بعمل
بنزل فيديو فيها رقص فالناس زي ما تقولي
ليه ما تعمليش عمل في استعراض فحاولت اقدم
ما اقدر امكانيات الصغيره جدا اللي انا
اعمل فيديو كليب راقص انا زيي زي اي فنان
دايما في حياه الفنان هتلاقي فيه تقلبات
وفي تعثرات وفيه اعتراض ركود سواء لاسباب
شخصيه واسباب مرض حتى بيبقى خارج عن ظروف
خارجه عن اراده الفنان وانا فعلا بعدت
الفتره طويله انا ستي عندي
مسلسل البارون مع استاذ حسين فهمي ان شاء
الله هينزل قريب على احدى المنصات لسه مش
عارفه فين بالضبط لانه في كلام على كذا
واحده هو مسلسل 15 حلقه دوري في صحفيه
مدير التحرير مقارنات كثيره لاحقت فيه ملك
الحلبه بعد بدا عرضه حيث تم تشبيهه بفيلم
الستار رغم ما كشفته الصحافه عن العمل على
الفيلم وانه بدا منذ وقت طويل في 2020
وتوقف عده مرات بسبب ازمه كوفي 19
جيد على المستوى الفني لكنه دون خصوصيه مع
مشغلين السنه بانه الاقبال على الفيلم ليس
كبيرا حتى الان عمرك ما حتكون بطل لما
تلاقي نفسك مصعب هذا اللي يقدم دوره
الفنان ياسين غزاوي حلمه من الصغر انه
يكون مصارع ويمكن هذا راح يخلينا بشكل او
باخر نقارن هذا الفيلم بفيلم ستار وبما ان
ستار نزل قبل فالطبيعي اننا نقول انه بعض
المشاهد من فيلم الملك الحلبه ماخوذه كوبي
بست من فيلم صبار تقليد خاصه المشهد اللي
فيه الولد يتفرج على المصارعه مع ابوه
والمشهد اللي فيه مصعب يلعب بالمصارعين في
العمل زي ما سوى ابراهيم الحجاج
استضافه الرياض مؤخرا في عرض خاص المخرج
التونسي انيس الاسود وفيلم قدحاب اللي تم
انتاجه عام 2021 ولازال يحصد عشرات
الجوائز حول العالم وسط اعجاب نقدي كبير
الفيلم تدور احداثه على مدار 92 دقيقه عن
طفل يتعرض لحادثه السير بعد ما تركوا
والده وسافر لايطاليا من خلال هجره غير
شرعيه ومع تطور الاحداث تنقلب حياته راسا
على عقب الفيلم من بطوله تشاما بن شعبان
جمال العروي درساف او ورده
لطفي والطفلين ياسين الترمسي وزكريا شبوب
وليد صغير عمره عمره 12 سنه اسمه قدحه هي
الكنيه متعه اسم نبيل في الفيلم يعيش
تجربه صعبه مع عائلته مع ابوهم
وتعرفنا الكبار يقروا كثير للصغار وياخذوا
قرارات صعبه في حق الصغار وهذا هو الفيلم
طفل يعيش قرارات الكبار من وجهه نظر دائره
بركلها
العديد ماليه من السعوديه في تجربه فريده
من نوعها وان شاء الله على مستوى التوزيع
هي شراكه ما بين الانتاج التونسي وتوزيع
السعود نختم مع المفاجاه الكبيره اللي
يسعد بها محمد حماقي جمهوره في حفل الاخير
بجده حيث استدعى على المسرح النجم الشريف
منير مرحبا فيك عازف لا يعرف عن موهبته
الكثيرين
منير رافق حماقي بالدرامز فعلا على المسرح
وهو بيغني اغنيه لو هتسيب وسط تفاعل كبير
من
[موسيقى]
قلبي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات